he does some really terrific work on
American Horror Story thank you and you
and I can tell you've had a lot of you
know it's it's actually it's nice
because it's a specific kind of role
where you can do different accents yeah
show is nice yeah and I know that you
take obviously acting it's your craft
you take it you're so good at you take
it so seriously that you probably like
doing that right yeah I do I do I got to
do the Baltimore accent in freak show
and I got so much crap from these
linguists at Columbia you know it was
like give me a break I mean you know
they were creep they were critiquing you
because I didn't have a dialect coach as
a matter of fact this is how I used to
warm up as I have the star-spangled
banner mm-hmm in Baltimore ease or
Ballmer ease as they say and this is how
you would you would say it yeah do you
like for me to sing that I would love
that yeah well um I'll tell you what why
don't you take this when we'll sing it
together
not on your list there wasn't I don't
know I'm not gonna do this right Oh
unfair I heard you sing I have the tiger
so yeah yeah you're right you're right
okay all right but you have to do it
phonetically okay yeah one two three
why don't you go first okay oh say can
you see lately what so proudly we hailed
at the twilight's last gleaming whose
broad stripes and faint
Mordo watch
[Music]
[Applause]
they proofread and need it was still
there oh say does that star-spangled
[Applause]
[Music]
you